when greta tunberg is in town i can tell
you i guess lively excuse me gents hi in
one second over from sky news i've got a
question for you
um you're among 10 000 people here let's
step onto the pavement get among 10 000
people here protesting greta toonberg's
here people from around the world what's
what's in your mind what are you
protesting about
it's just the climate change and it's
our future
it's our future and we have to act now
to help it
what's your name henry henry well done
henry hello there come and stand over
here
what's your name pal
what do you think about climate change
what are you protesting about today
[Music]
um people take action
and
[Applause]
[Music]
fuels and stuff like that thanks man
thanks very much greta timbers about to
pass i don't know if you can see her
just uh
[Music]
just behind that sign stop come over
with us now greta timber very much
protected by
this fridays for futures movement the
one she founded and you can get a sense
of the media hysteria that surrounds the
swedish 18 year old now
there are many people
funneled into
the street in glasgow heading towards
george square in the city center
something like 10 000 people are
expected to
attend
and let's try and grab a chat with uh
with some of them hello sir we're from
sky news hi what's what's in your mind
today what's the message here
i'm here because
i traveled from estonia where we also
need to do much more climate action than
we're doing now
and i mean i wish i didn't have to do it
i wish i could be at school but if it's
our future and so many people's presence
at stake then we have to do it
thank you very much indeed enjoy the
rest of your stay in glasgow hello sir
hi what are you marching about
hello excuse me hi we're from sky news
can we have a chat
tell me um
we can see your sign there there's no
planet b
what are you protesting about
i'm trying to help the planet because
it's dying
from climate change
are you worried about that yes because
we might not be able to be lived by
2055.
that isn't worrying
yeah
what's your name jessica what's your
second name jessica
thank you very much tell me what's um
what's in your mind here today
well i'm i'm i'm worried i'm i'm just
worried the same as she is about the
future i i'm a huge nature lover and
it's it's just sad to see all all the
habits getting destroyed and animals
going extinct you know
and do you feel excluded from the talks
there's a lot of talk here though yes
you feel shut up
see i i feel actually quite anxious it
feels like you can't do anything about
it
all this bad stuff is happening and it
feels like you just can't do anything
you know
so we're just trying to show we are here
to support you know
great thank you very much do you want to
can we have a quick chat with you what
do you what do you think about the
climate and the action that's being
taken or not being taken i just think
it's quite worrying and we're trying to
do my part with my sisters and stuff so
just yeah helping the cause
great thank you very much indeed for
your time let's try and pick another
couple of people out from the crowd
hello sir hi we're from sky news hi
tell me what's in your mind here today
in the center of glasgow
what sorry i i i didn't pick that up
what's on your mind what's on my mind
well actually interestingly
part of our work is to kind of be in the
space to offer mediation or dialogue if
it's needed amongst crowds protesters
the police and other of the bodies here
so we're really here to observe the
interaction get a flavor of it and it
seems it's settled it's calm
and
clearly those who want to get their
message across it looks like they're
able to do so that's an issue because
during the week on wednesday there were
very untidy scenes in the centre of
glasgow police chasing protesters left
right and center
that has to be a fear and anxiety today
uh what do you think about that is that
legitimate fear that we will see this
descend into something as messy as
wednesday it's a fair question and
certainly from what we've observed so
far
it does look like people are
acting in a way that it's going to
stay calm at least
my interest will be as we gather and get
further into the streets further towards
george square will that dynamic change
in any way um i guess the other question
would be is from the police authorities
and they're planning is what have they
considered from that experience from a
few days ago and what changes they have
made to make sure and try to ensure that
it's as positive and constructive as
possible today all right so thanks for
watching your time welcome thank you uh
here in the center of glasgow this marks
something like a mile to go further into
time where we will hear speeches by
greta turnburg and others so let's leave
you with a picture of the procession the
march of fridays
for future